all right we have an update on a story
CBS this morning has been reporting on
for more than a year the EPA is banning
the consumer use of methylene chloride
toxic chemical used in paint strippers
that is linked to dozens of deaths but
the agency is not banning the chemical
for commercial use which critics say
leaves workers unprotected drew Wynn
died in 2017 after using a paint
stripper containing methylene chloride
he bought at a local hardware store
since his death his family fought to get
the product off retailers shelves they
told Ana Warner Friday's EP announcement
was bittersweet
we feel like we did what we set out to
do for him which was what to take what
killed him off the shelves but it's not
a celebration it doesn't bring him back
I think it's a step in the right
direction the job isn't completely done
overall we'd like to see nothing
chloride completely unavailable Wendy
Hartley is 21 year old son Kevin died
after using a paint stripper while on
the job she says the partial ban would
not have protected him in a statement
Hartley said quote workers who use
methylene chloride will now be left
unprotected and at risk of health issues
or death I will continue my fight until
the EPA does its job the agency says
that it's considering a proposal for a
certification and training program for
workers who use the chemical
commercially well it's good to hear that
they've made those changes I can
remember those reports that that she has
done and that's proof that good
reporting and speaking up can cause
government agencies to change
jiaying on the story more work needs to
be done clearly